we welcome you to southern california
another scorcher out there today as the
angels will
host the houston astros final game of
the season series
final game of this four game weekend set
the astros have lost three heartbreakers
so far
in this series hoping to salvage one
game before they head out to oakland
i'm on the mound for the angels this
will be his fourth appearance second
start no record
he's throwing the ball well though 13
and two third innings 10 hits 11
strikeouts five walks in an era very
respectable 2.63
michael brandley steps in tucker's on
deck and he will walk to the play with
reddick in first base as bradley strikes
out on the breaking ball
good decision not to be going on that
one went back to our breaking ball
brainly trying to lift that one make
contact unable to do so
now bring up kyle tucker and that ball
is hit to right field hit pretty well
looking up is taylor ward and kyle
tucker has done it again
tucker's eighth home run rbi's 36
and 37 his second home run of his career
against berea in four at bats
and the astros out in front two nothing
from
valdez he has been doing a lot of damage
with that curveball we know it is the
year of spin
and he has been going out there with it
51.7 percent
curveball with percentage 18 of his last
19 strikeouts
via the ball in those last two starts
angelton simmons leading off
he's on a nice little run lately foul
tip and that'll be a quick strikeout of
simmons
from valadez needs three pitches to get
his first strikeout today
i'm a berea delivers to let me diaz the
0-1 and diaz hits this in the air pretty
deep down the left field line
long run for upton toward the corner
fighting the sun
was that ball fair yes it was and it's a
home run for
let me diaz and the astros lead grows to
three to nothing
jared walsh starting first basement
today ball sits one towards second base
and
unable to make the play on it is toru
apartment that's diaz
and more than likely gets credited with
the base in that should be an absolute
error
as diaz his best bull fighter
impersonation
taylor ward coming to the plate
dribbler left side is gonna be a tough
play mayfield with bear hand goes to
first base and it pulls toro off the bag
the run scores
infield base zipper taylor ward the
angels are down three to one
reddick coming up
called strike three inside part of the
plate
two down adjustment on that one reddick
didn't like the call but it looked like
it got the inside corner
here's anthony rendon that is out toward
left field hit well moving back on it
is tucker and that one is gone
big fly for anthony rendon and we are
tied at three here in the third
randy madone three-run home run
yesterday two-run home run today and
just like that we are tied up at three
adele standing at third stassey at first
one out
walsh had a base hit quotation and he'll
sky this one out to right center field
has pretty good depth springer drifting
back having troubles with it will make
the catch on the track
throw comes into second a double score
easily it's a sac fly and the angels
lead at 4-3
simmons with a count of one and two
chops one over the head of valdez diaz
backhand steps on the bag that's a nice
double play turn by a led miss diaz
to get two outs on a ball up the middle
[Applause]
and down goes maldonado went away
mayfield with a fly ball to center field
his first a b
popped up left side not very deep
simmons going out up to coming in
upton and simmons makes a terrific play
upton stopped running because he thought
simmons was going to get it simmons
slowed down because
upton was going to get it and then
angelton simmons just took charge
big ad on rbi out there now for franklin
barretto
ground ball past toro that's a base hit
and an rbi
the old add-on run as you pointed out
5-3 angels
[Applause]
franklin barretto going the other way
carlos correa was part of that three-run
outburst as he doubled into right-center
field
now carlos hits a 3-1 pitch high and
deep this game
is now a one-run game as correa puts one
into the rocks in left center field
carlos correa his fourth home run of the
year the astros have the tying run on
base with nobody out
toro sends one to right field this ball
is going to be down for a hit diaz on
the move to third
ward plays it off the wall gary pettis
is going to send diaz around here comes
rendipo's throw
it's wide and the astros have tied the
game on the rbi double
by abraham toro lefty on lefty here
walsh against valdez
infield is in on the right shot chopper
and this will go into right field to
base in the angels have taken the lead
stasi will turn it head to third
three singles in the inning in the lead
luis red heap will get his first plate
appearance try it again
and he walked up bases loaded walk and
seven to five angels and still nobody
out
not to know for three with a walk upton
pulls into the left field there's a base
hit
it'll bring home two randhifa will stop
at
second and the angels are opening it up
here in the bottom of the eighth and
against nine to five
yes punch out that's it they'll take it
and the sweet the four-game sweep of the
astros by the halos five wins in a row